should the prime minister resign if he
misled parliament
absolutely and i think dominic grieve a
respected law officer that used to be in
the house of commons has made it clear
if you reach the ministerial code if you
mislead the house of commons and it's an
open and shut case
you should go and and i think okay
really everything we've seen over the
course of the last 36 hours what's
important in all of this is the public
reaction and so many people when you've
had them on your program so many
newspapers have covered the stories
those that lost their loved ones in the
spring of 2020 they weren't able to
visit the relatives in hospital not able
to visit the relatives and care homes
not able to grieve properly not a kind
of funeral that people would have
expected and when they see a prime
minister a government that is prepared
to defy their own rules and party in a
way
that they have done this really sticks
in the in the throat of people it's
unacceptable behavior and for that if
nothing else it has to go but dominic is
right that if you reach the ministerial
code if you mislead or lie to parliament
then that's a serious offense and you
know because of all of this we've
glossed over the fact that i think there
were as many as five occasions of prime
minister's questions last week that the
prime minister wasn't truthful let's not
forget this is a man that pro-rolled
parliament he shut down parliament was
found wanting in the highest court of
the land a man that's prepared to
breach international
treaties a man that puts his friends
into the house awards if they need large
sums of money to the conservative party
all the scandal over the refurbishment
of the flat and downing street this is a
man that's cavalier in his approach to
government i have to say i don't believe
he's fit for purpose i don't believe
he's fit to be prime minister and verb
dominic grieve is right
in the end this is going to come down to
the conservative mps are they now at the
stage for they recognize that they can't
tolerate this man as prime minister
anymore he has to go i suspect he won't
resign of his own volition he needs to
be removed because
and this is not hyperbole this is a man
that's actually a threat to our
democracy because of the way that he
behaves he's treating government number
10 as a personal placing and it has to
stop it has to end
but will it
it has to and i think
what i witnessed yesterday talking to
conservative mps is that i think a
number have crossed the rubicon they now
see
that this is a man that simply cannot be
left in office to behave
the way that he's doing um it simply
isn't acceptable what is going on
and we need to make sure that all of us
individually collectively that we bring
this to an end it can't carry on any
longer than it has done he's insulted
the intelligence he's a breach of trust
with the public through his behavior and
i think the public are demanding that he
goes politicians have now got to step up
to the plate
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time let's see what happens
prime minister's questions later on
today thank you mr bradford